We've been talking about the avalanche
of apostasy for several years now. If
you're not familiar with the avalanche
of apostasy, it refers to the
skyrocketing apostasy rates in Islam.
Muslim leaders are in panic mode because
so many Muslims are leaving their
religion.
>> 24% of Muslim youth are leaving Islam.
Previously according to me when an when
a person from Saudi Arabia or from the
Gulf country went to America or went to
western country the chances that you
know they would deviate from the dean
would be maybe one or 2% that's it but
nowadays the chances are more than 25%.
And if we don't take constructive steps
to deal with this,
it is going to become an avalanche.
For some of you younger viewers, this is
completely normal. You hear from
ex-Muslims all the time. But if you're
my age or older, and if you were paying
attention 20 years ago, you didn't see
very many ex-Muslims.
There were ex-Muslims, but they didn't
talk about it much because they didn't
want to become targets. So, there were
only a handful of publicly visible
ex-Muslims, people like Nabil, Brother
Rasheed, Ayan Hersy Ali, and so on. Fast
forward to today, and I already know
when I see a video that has anything to
do with leaving Islam that the comment
section is going to be filled with
ex-Muslims and people talking about all
their ex-Muslim friends. A few hours
ago, I even put this to the test. A
short popped up from the archive. The
archive made a short from a section of
one of my videos about a Muslim calling
into Hamza's den to complain about all
the Afghan Muslims who are leaving Islam
in Virginia. It's under a minute, so
we'll just watch it. Recently, a Muslim
entered Hamza's den to complain about
all the Afghan Muslims who were leaving
Islam in his area. There is a major
major concern here in Virginia. We have
we have lots of Afghans literally
leaving Islam. They are leaving it by
the masses. A lot of them, guys. A lot
of them.
>> He's just talking about Afghan Muslims
leaving Islam in his city. Nowhere else.
Muslims are leaving Islam. Everywhere
there's an internet connection. For 14
centuries, Muslim shakes were able to
keep their followers insulated,
shielded, protected from ever hearing
any response to their ridiculous claims
about Muhammad and the Quran. Fast
forward to the 21st century when anyone
with an internet connection can look up
what their shakes are claiming about
Muhammad and the Quran. And what do you
get? Get an avalanche of apostasy.
>> It is going to become an avalanche.
Now, I already knew what I was going to
find when I went to the comments, and
the comments did not disappoint. Let's
have a look. I am Afghan. I converted to
Christianity. Same, bro. Was it hard for
you? Like, family-wise,
even in Nigeria, there are lots of
conversions to Christianity. I'm not an
Afghan, but I left Islam and converted
to the Christian faith. Best decision
ever in my life. Ex-Muslim from South
Africa. I hope the whole world opens
their eyes. As an Afghan Christian, I am
so happy to hear this news. Christianity
saved my life. Jesus loves all of us. I
am from Afghanistan living in Canada. I
am getting baptized this Easter vigil.
It has been the best decision of my
life. I truly feel the presence of the
Lord since I accepted Christ into my
life. I have seen all the darkness of
Islam growing up as an Afghan Muslim.
All we can do is continue to pray for
our Muslim brothers and sisters to come
to our dear Lord Jesus Christ. He is the
only truth. I got to this journey
through dreams and visions when I had
zero knowledge of Jesus Christ at the
time. Reading the word of God and being
led through this by the Holy Spirit is
what has brought me closer and closer to
Christ. I love him so much. Please pray
for my family so that they too can come
to the truth and have eternal life. Love
you all. Christ be with you. Totally
unrelated, but here's a bonus testimony.
I was a Chinese atheist and was baptized
in 2005. Praise the Lord. I have a new
classmate from Afghanistan and today we
had a chat and he told me he is an
ex-Muslim. After he read and studied
Quran, he left the cult. I was so happy
for him. I had to hug him and tell him
about Jesus.
Ex-Muslim from Afghanistan here. Praise
the Lord. He saved me from my dark phase
of life two months ago and brought me to
light and peace. Today at 11:00 a.m. I
will get baptized. Thank you, my king.
Lord, protect our Christian avengers.
Ex-Muslim from Morocco here. I
apostatized because of the internet.
Ex-Muslim from Malaysia here. Malaysian
can like this comment. I'm an ex-Muslim
from West Africa. I was born Muslim, but
honestly, I never felt at peace. My soul
was always yearning closer to God. Jesus
Christ is the only way to God. What I
understand is that whenever you
sincerely seek for God, he saw you Jesus
Christ. No doubt. Honestly, there is no
Muslim that can answer my questions
without feeling guilty. In Egypt, around
two millions left Islam, mostly became
atheists and others converted to
Christianity. In Arabic, we call them
Abberin. God bless you, David. It is
also happening in Iran. Approximately a
million have left Islam. Hundreds of
thousands mosques are now vacant. In the
Netherlands, we recently had several
secret baptisms. A Turkish church began
in censored for security reasons. We had
baptisms of Muslims from Yemen, Syria,
Iran, Morocco.
January 2025. As an ex-Muslim, only
Islam or communism can destroy our
entire way of life and freedom on earth.
I am from Middle East Muslim family. I
became Christian in my 40s. I am not
Afghan, but I know a lot of Somali
people are leaving Islam with the truth
being revealed and lies exposed. I am
one of those and have converted to
Christianity. Praise our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ. I'm Iranian-B born woman
who was lost now found by Jesus Christ
my Lord, my savior, my redeemer and my
sanctifier belong to his one holy
universal church. Thank you most holy
trinity for giving me Jesus his our holy
mother, St. Joseph and all the holy
angels and saints. Thank you Jesus for
all your sufferings for love of us
wretched creatures. Thank you Jesus for
all the sacraments you instituted to
continuously nourish our souls. I bind
myself to your holy humanity, to your
holy divinity, and to your holy divine
will. Truly blessed beyond words, thy
will be done. I'm a Muslim from
Bangladesh. I want to embrace Jesus as
my savior, but local churches are not
responding online. Please do something
for the peoples like me. I want to leave
ferocity, violence, hatred. I need a
peaceful life. Local churches in
Bangladesh are not responding online.
Why?
Probably because they're worried about
bringing in ex-Muslims who might be a
target.
But guess what, churches? Sometimes you
just got to take a chance. Bonus
testimony. I'm an exhindu. I accept
Jesus Christ is my Lord and Savior.
Amen. Bonus testimony. I left Hinduism
and accepted Christianity. Praise to the
living God. Where I live in Virginia, a
lot of Afghans are leaving Islam. Many
moved out here and we had a huge influx
after the withdrawal. I've also been
talking with some still there who wish
to convert. I am Indonesian was Islamic
practitioner but years ago I logged out
from cult religion and find the truth in
Christianity by the grace of God alone I
found something that set me free. Thank
you Jesus Christ. Glory be to God alone.
I live in Northern Virginia. The DC area
is famous for major migrant communities
from Afghanistan, Iran, Pakistan,
Ethiopia, Sudan, etc. Once my Uber
driver was Afghan and he told me most
Afghani Americans he knows drink beer
and don't care about halal. There are
multiple Arabic, Pakistani, Persian and
Pashtune Afghani churches in my area and
many people are receiving the gospel in
Turkey. There are many people becoming
Christian. I left Islam one year and a
half year ago not Afghan. Iranians too
ex-Muslim here. Ex-Muslim from Algeria.
I left Islam 20 years ago. I speak the
language of Afghans and I observed that
many of them are abandoning Islam. Also,
the Taliban officially talked about
that. I live in the UK. I know about 25
people who have left this year. Met some
Syrians in the UK. They left Islam after
the behavior of Muslims in Syria.
Militant Islam, the gift that keeps on
giving. I am Turkish from an Islamic
background and became a Christian in the
midst of 2019. Wish I had found Jesus
even earlier. Was the greatest grace and
best decision of my life also for all of
eternity. After reading the Quran and
the biography of Muhammad, I left Islam
and became a Christian. I am very happy.
I have spoken with people from Iran who
have left Islam and sought asylum in the
West. Muslims from rigid caiphates are
leaving in droves. They've had enough. I
have an Afghan friend who her family
converted to Christianity and an Iranian
friend who doesn't believe in Islam and
just believes in God. I also have left
Islam. However, I never asked to be born
in a Muslim family. I can't accept that
I am labeled Muslim just because I was
born in a Muslim family. I'm Turkish and
I converted to Christianity 8 years ago.
My bro in Ethiopia, the young Orthodox
Christian, bring about Muhammad each
words from Quran. For Ethiopian Muslims,
they are leaving Islam to Christianity.
The internet is kryptonite for Islam. I
personally know several people who have
converted to Christianity from Islam.
No two ex-Muslims, they are happy. You
can see the happiness on their faces. I
left Islam 14 years ago at the age of
22. Not only in Afghanistan, 2 million
Indonesian Muslims are abandoning Islam
every year. In 10 years, Indonesia will
not be an Islam majority country.
2 million Muslims abandoning Islam every
year in Indonesia seems way too high to
me. even during the avalanche of
apostasy. So, I looked it up. Turns out
this figure doesn't come from
Christians. It comes from Muslims.
Here's the story from International
Christian Concern. An Islamic social
media campaign known as Save Miam is
raising awareness of the spread of
Christianity throughout Indonesia, and
it's using controversial statistics and
statements to do so. The campaign's
manager stated that 2 million Muslims
convert to Christianity every year in
the country. He added that Indonesia
would cease to be a predominantly Muslim
nation by 2035.
Critics and commentators have accused
the campaign's team of being alarmist,
creating unnecessary religious tension,
and giving inaccurate information to
raise more funds for their activities.
Indonesia boasts the largest Muslim
population in the world with more than
212 million Muslims. Official figures
estimate that about 11% of the
population are Christians. However,
several Indonesian church leaders
believe this is a huge underestimation,
placing the actual number of Christians
between 20% and 30% of the population.
So, the 2 million figure comes from
Muslims themselves, but it seems way too
high. If they'd said 100,000 or
something, that would be believable. It
seems like they're inflating the numbers
because they know tons of Muslims are
leaving Islam, and they're saying it's
millions to try to induce panic in the
Muslim population, presumably to get
more DA donations or to incite violence
against Christians. But whatever the
correct figure is, everyone agrees that
lots of Indonesian Muslims are leaving
Islam.
In Austria and Germany, many Afghan
Muslims left their religion. Afghan
atheist here. Atheist. Atheist.
2008 called they want their new atheism
back. Iranians here. Iranians are
converting to Christianity. Zoroastrian
or becoming atheists in masses. Bonus
testimony. I left Mormon to
Christianity.
I converted two Afghans in Sweden. Jesus
always wins. And finally, this is why
they want to build Epic City in Texas to
shield people from internet so people
can't see through their lies.
Absolutely correct. Epic City is
supposed to be a future Muslim city in
Texas. Why are they trying to make a
Muslim city? Because being in non-Muslim
cities just isn't working very well. All
the comments we just read are from a
single YouTube short. Ex-Muslims are
everywhere. This is very, very different
from 20 years ago. There's a lot that's
wrong with the world. But if you want to
help Muslims leave Islam, if you want to
share the gospel with Muslims,
you are living at the beginning of the
golden age. So stop complaining, stop
procrastinating, and get involved. Learn
how to respond to common Muslim
objections to Christianity. Anyone can
do it. Learn how to respond to Muslim
arguments for Islam. Anyone can do it.
Learn the Islamic dilemma. Anyone can do
it. And relentlessly share what you
learn. Let's all work together and get
that apostasy rate up to 100%.
>> You
[Music]
just
fine on me. This is a power of religion.
There's a reason to it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.